- [Morgan] Hey, everyone,
thanks for coming.
Welcome to Best Practices for Performing
Custom Code Transformations
with Agentic AI.
My name is Morgan Lunt.
I'm a senior product manager
on the AWS Transform Team,
and I'm here with Venu.
- [Venu] Hey, I'm Venu Vasudevan.
I'm a senior specialist
solutions architect
with NextGen Developer Experience Team.
- [Morgan] This would be helpful.
(Venu chuckles)
So what we're gonna talk about today
is the challenge of technical debt,
which I'm sure you're
all very familiar with.
I'm not gonna spend too much time on that.
Some scaled remediation options,
things that you may be aware of
and some things that may be new to you.
Some best practices that we've
discovered internally in AWS
when managing tech debt
at significant scale.
And then the thing you're all here for
is the live code demo.
We'll actually show you
the tools that we use.
So the problem with tech debt,
it's big, it costs a lot of
money, it takes a lot of time,
it slows down your innovation
It prevents you from being able to deliver
new features to customers.
It prevents you from being
able to hire developers
that really understand your stack
and can contribute to it properly.
And it may bring security vulnerabilities
and all sorts of bad things.
So generally speaking, tech debt, bad.
Different kinds of technical debt.
You can have security
and compliance risks,
especially if you're in a
compliance-oriented industry
like healthcare or finance.
But even for any company,
a security vulnerability
can cause massive PR
issues, monetary loss,
all sorts of things that you
probably don't want to happen.
Maintenance burden.
Sometimes it can get to a
point where you're just doing,
feels like you're doing patching
and addressing vulnerabilities and CVEs,
and you're not actually spending time
developing things that
your customers want.
Performance limitations.
So your things can get slow.
They can get crufty.
You can have large applications built up
over 10, 20, 30, 40 years
that when they were initially
built were well designed,
but after caking mud on the
ball for many, many years,
it becomes unwieldy.
And this can also cost you money
in terms of being more
expensive to run on bigger VMs.
And finally, strategic misalignment.
So a lot of customers
that I've spoken with
work at companies that were
acquired by other companies,
and companies that are
acquired by other companies
may use a different tech stack
than the rest of the
companies in the portfolio.
So there's often a desire
within corporations
to have some sort of standardization
and internal alignment
for the tech stacks they use,
the libraries they use, the APIs they use,
the vendors they use, which are gonna have
their own different APIs,
and all that fun stuff.
So these are some customers
that I've worked with
pretty closely over this last year.
Air Canada has a big issue
with thousands and thousands,
I think tens of thousands
of Lambda functions
running on deprecated versions of Node
and deprecated versions of Python.
And due to compliance
and internal standards,
they desperately need to upgrade these,
and it takes a lot of
time and a lot of manpower
to go through every
single Lambda individually
and try to upgrade it
to the latest version of Node or Python.
Twitch, our friends inside of Amazon,
have a lot of Golang code.
They're kind of unique in Amazon.
Not a lot of people use
Go, but Twitch does.
And a lot of it's
written using AWS SDK v1.
They wanna migrate to AWS SDK v2.
They have over 900 applications.
I think they projected, originally,
11 developer years of
manual effort to do that.
QAD is a major ERP vendor.
They make software for manufacturers
that make products that
we all probably use.
They have a piece of software
that's evolved over 20-plus years,
and their customers have
built customizations
on top of this ERP software
to do things particular to that customer.
Super useful if you're a
customer and wanna augment
this off the shelf ERP with
your own functionality,
but over time this builds up cruft
and makes it very challenging for QAD,
for the vendor themself
to publish new versions of
their ERP 'cause everyone's got
kind of a one-off special little thing.
And so they have this challenge
of moving these
customer-done customizations
onto their common customization framework
on their newer platform versions.
And then MongoDB.
They and their customers
have a lot of Java code.
A lot of this Java code
is on Java 8, Java 11.
They really wanna get it up
to Java 21 or later versions,
and that's easier said than done.
So there's a lot of existing approaches
for doing code modernization at scale
in an automated fashion.
There's good old rule-based automation.
So this is stuff like ast-grep,
managing abstract syntax trees,
using something like OpenRewrite.
And these are good tools
if you can get them to do what you want.
They'll do it deterministically,
and they'll do it reliably,
but they can be kind of
brittle and kind of inflexible.
If you introduce a new piece of code
that isn't exactly following
the same conventions
as the ones that you wrote your
transformation recipe with,
it's probably not gonna work.
And it takes kind of some
specialized expertise
to write these sorts of recipes.
You have to know how to navigate
an abstract syntax tree.
You're kind of like writing
code to manipulate code
and dealing in this kind
of conceptual higher level,
and so it's a little tricky
if you haven't done it before.
And because of that, there's
a bit of a higher startup cost
in using approaches like that.
General purpose coding AI
has gotten really good.
The Kiros and the Cloud Codes
of the world are awesome.
You should all use them.
I love them.
I use them a lot.
But one tricky part
about doing large scale code
modernization efforts with them
is that there's no easy way right now
to enforce consistency
across a bunch of developers
trying to do the same task
using those same tools.
I might ask a Kiro to do,
upgrade a Java runtime,
and it'll probably do it,
but it may follow different conventions
and different patterns
than if Venu does it.
And we're gonna end up with disparate code
that may not follow the standards
and use the right libraries
that my organization wants to use.
These tools tend to be designed
to be run with a human in the loop,
with a human sitting at
the keyboard, driving it,
watching what the agent does,
poking it this direction or that
which, again, fantastic if
you're doing something once,
not so fantastic if you're
doing it a hundred times,
a thousand times.
That human cost, even though
it's a significant acceleration
from someone sitting out
and doing this work themself
with no assistance, is still real.
There's still significant
cost to clicky-clacky,
driving a coding agent on the keyboard.
And another issue with doing it this way
is that teams' learnings remain siloed.
So if over the course of an
API migration, you discover,
oh, there's an incompatibility
between these two particular versions,
I had to do this workaround,
you learn that, you discover that,
but some other team on the
other side of the country,
on the other side of the world
that's doing the same
migration in your organization,
they're gonna go have to
discover that themself.
They're gonna run into the same issue,
and unless you're really
good about updating wikis
and looking at those wikis,
that that learning is lost.
You're gonna run into the
same problems several times,
and that's not as efficient as can be.
So what do we need?
We need a code transformation,
a scalable code transformation mechanism
that has a low barrier to entry.
It's easy to get started with,
doesn't take a lot of
specialized knowledge.
It's designed for automation.
It can be scripted together
and just kind of set up
to run in a headless, without
human interaction fashion,
something that you can teach once
and you can run it everywhere,
and that gets better every time
so you don't lose these learnings
that individual developers
are coming across.
Enter AWS Transform custom.
This is my baby.
I'm the PM on this product.
We've been working on
it for the last year.
This was released GA on Monday.
We're all very excited and proud of it,
and that's what we're gonna
be showing you in a minute.
So AWS Transform custom
is intended to discover,
to learn from you any
sort of code pattern,
API upgrade, runtime
upgrade, framework upgrade.
I have people doing things as
wild as converting VBA script
embedded in a Excel spreadsheet
to maintainable Python code,
and it's working okay for that.
Or rewriting bash scripts to Rye,
which is a Rust-based scripting language.
Like, the more I learn about
how customers are using this,
the more scared I become
because there are some
weird stuff out there.
Because you can teach it
your own custom code transformation,
you can do your weird stuff
with it, which is cool.
And because you are teaching the agent,
if it's doing it wrong, you
can tell it to do it different
and to do it better until
it does do the right thing,
and it does it consistently enough
that you feel comfortable to
start running it at scale.
It continuously learns.
It gets better every time.
We'll show you how that works in a moment.
And it's easy to run at scale.
So the main components
of AWS Transform custom
is our CLI, that you'll see in a moment,
which you interact with
using natural language.
So you tell it,
hey, I wanna blah the
blah from blah to blah,
and it's gonna say, okay, cool.
What the heck is a blah?
Do you have some documentation on blah?
How do I go from blah to blah?
And we've encoded all these best practices
that we've discovered internally at AWS
for doing scaled code
modernization into the agent,
so it's gonna know the right
kinds of questions to ask you.
If you say, I wanna do an API upgrade,
it's gonna say, cool, do
you have the swaggers?
Do you have the the API documentation?
If you say you want to add
a whole bunch of test cases,
it's gonna say, okay, can
you give me an example
of, like, the kinds of style
you like your test cases to be written in?
Or if you want to emit
metrics in a different way,
it'll ask you for the schema.
So it shouldn't take, like, a
whole lot of domain expertise
to build this transformation
that you're gonna want to apply at scale.
Once you've built something
that you're comfortable with,
you're pretty happy with the performance,
you've tested it on a few repos,
executing it at scale is
really straightforward
because it is ACLI.
It's a CLI that can be driven by a human,
talking to an agent,
like you're all used to
doing these days, I imagine.
Or it can be driven by a machine.
So our syntax is totally
deterministic and machine drivable.
You put a bunch of commands,
a bunch of arguments in
a command telling it,
run this transformation on this repo
following these conditions
and blah, blah, blah,
and it'll just do it.
So it's really easy to
write a shell script,
to pull down your code
from wherever it is,
GitLab, GitHub, Bitbucket...
I don't know, what other places...
And transform it and push
it where it needs to go,
send it for code review,
send it straight to prod.
I probably wouldn't recommend
that, but you do you.
Continual learning.
Both during execution of a transformation,
an agent is just gonna record notes
about what it encountered.
So if it goes down like a
really deep self-debug path,
trying to deal with some
weird incompatibility
it discovered during execution
and then I had to backtrack
and try something else,
it's gonna remember that next time
and try the shorter path.
Likewise, if you do an
interactive transformation
sitting there and watching the agent,
which is an option you can do,
and you see it going off
the rails, you can tell it,
hey, don't do that, do
this, it'll remember that
and hopefully not do it next time.
So how's the process work?
The first thing you do is
you have some sort of expert.
They could be on a centralized team.
They can be someone that
owns a particular service
that a lot of other teams are consuming,
someone who kind of
knows what they're doing
about this transformation.
They're gonna sit down with our agent,
and they're gonna describe what
they wanna do and go through
that transformation
definition building phase.
A transformation definition
is this term we invented
to represent the agent's understanding
of a particular transformation.
So it's a combination of
some markdown files, a RAG,
and a database of learnings
that the agents encountered
during its executions.
And this is something that
we consider to be your IP.
We don't look at it,
we don't learn from it.
If you wanna sell it, if
you wanna keep it secret,
if you wanna open source it,
that's none of my business.
The transformation that
you built is yours.
So someone's gonna create
an initial transformation definition.
They're gonna execute it a few times
on some local repos, and they're
gonna look at the output.
And they're gonna tell the agent,
you screwed this up, you
missed this edge case,
you should do this differently,
and it's gonna update that
transformation definition,
and then you run it again,
and then you run it again.
And hopefully, after three or four times
and not 30 or 40 times, it's
starting to get to the point
where you're like, okay, this
is, like, doing what I want
for the most part, cool.
At that point, you're ready
to share your transformation.
So we make that really easy
because we have this notion
of a transformation definition registry,
which is just something
within an AWS account.
If you give someone the
right IM permissions
and the transformation
definition is just a,
it's an honorable AWS resource.
We're not reinventing the wheel here
with permissioning and resources.
It's the concepts you already
know and you're used to.
You can make the transformation definition
available to other users
in your organization.
They can pull it down.
They can execute it on their code.
They can propose changes back
to it, and everybody is happy.
And once you have the
application owning team
somewhat happy with the quality,
you can start running it at scale.
And you can do that in the
form of a push campaign
if you like, where some central team
pulls down a whole bunch of code
from a whole bunch of teams,
executes a transformation,
and sends the resultant
code out to be reviewed
by the application owning team.
Or you can do it pull campaign style,
where you tell the application teams,
hey, you must blah the blah.
There's a top down mandate
that you must blah the blah,
but I'm gonna give you this thing.
You could try running it.
Hopefully, it does most of the job for you
and makes your life a little easier.
And humans verify, and
the continual learning
goes back into the
transformation definition.
Super cool, right?
We have been eating our own
dog food, as we do at Amazon.
We've built a whole
bunch of transformations
that we thought were useful
using this, and we have done
some pretty comprehensive
benchmarking on them
using internal AWS code
and some open source code.
And so we have this little
menu of transformations here,
notably, Java, Python, and
Node runtime version upgrades,
AWS SDK version upgrades
for those languages as well
that we are confident in,
that I'm putting my name on,
that we believe are pretty
good, and we give to you.
And you can just run them.
You don't have to create a
new transformation at all.
If you're trying to do Java, Python,
or Node runtime upgrades,
or AWS SDK upgrades,
just use these
and they should get you
most of the way there.
And if they don't, tell
me, and I need to fix it.
Beyond that, we have a
couple of early access things
that we've also released.
So a tech debt analysis/documentation
transformation.
This one's pretty cool.
It'll go through all of your code
if you've got something really
old and poorly documented
and generate what Venu and I think
is like a pretty comprehensive
documentation set of it,
including entity relationships,
sequence diagrams,
lots of pretty images, full
dependency trees and stuff.
It's like every way you could
think of to represent code
without having the code itself,
we try to to capture in here.
And as a bonus, it gives
you a little report in there
that says, hey, you're using
a super outdated version
of this and that and this,
and this is vulnerable,
and like, you might wanna
check these things out.
And then we also have an
upgrade that we're working on
with the Graviton team in AWS
to convert Java code that uses x86,
that has dependencies on
x86 libraries to Graviton.
That's early access, doing
pretty well in benchmarks.
We'll probably mainline
that one pretty soon.
These are no setup for you.
They're validated by us.
We have a pretty comprehensive
benchmarking infrastructure
to try to get the quality
on these really good.
Beyond that, you can build custom things.
You can build VBA to Python.
You can build something crazy and unholy
if you really want to.
I would recommend using
it for API upgrades,
language version upgrades.
You can use it for
language-to-language conversions,
but I would caveat, like,
in a localized context.
If you have like a 500,000
million line of code,
old dot net app and you
wanna reimplement it in Java,
you're probably not
gonna have a great time.
The models aren't quite that good yet.
But if you've got like
a whole bunch of scripts
that you wanna convert from
one language to another
that are relatively self-contained,
it'll work pretty well
for something like that.
Best practices, 'cause
that's what we're here for.
That's like the title
of this thing, I think.
Pilots.
Start building a transformation
that's not very hard
and then just run it on a
few things at small scale.
And that's how you get
a feel for the efficacy.
That's how you get a feel
for what it's going to cost.
So pricing for this is
entirely usage based.
It's based on agent minutes,
which is just kind of an abstraction
on top of our cost for
providing the service.
It's 0.035 cents per agent minute.
A typical thousand-line
Lambda costs about a buck.
I think a 5,000-line Java runtime upgrade
costs like four or five bucks.
We really intentionally
priced this thing very low
to make it up on scale.
So we want to incentivize
y'all to create transformations
that do what you wanna do and unleash them
and just build a lot of scale.
Plan, refine, pilot, I think
you all get the picture there.
And another best practice is
use your current workflow.
There's a lot of code
transformation products out there
that I've seen that kind of ask you
to onboard to a totally
new way of doing things,
and I think that's lame.
So we have intentionally built this
to be a CLI that has very
minimal dependencies,
that has a dependency on
Node, a dependency on Git,
and a dependency to have
an external connection
to our servers, to our AWS servers.
If you have a machine that
has a Linux environment...
MacOS also works, WSL also works.
Venu is gonna demo this on WSL.
Has those dependencies, you
can run your transformation.
So people stick it in pipelines.
People stick it in Docker containers.
People stick it in AWS Batch jobs.
People stick it on
laptops in their basement.
Like, I don't care how you run it.
Whatever works with your current way
of doing code modernization and
doing deployments and stuff,
it's designed to be
minimal and just slot in.
And I would be remiss if I did not plug
our AWS Transform web application.
So if you heard about
AWS Transform last year,
this is all there was to it.
We didn't have the CLI.
The CLI and custom is the
brand new thing this year.
But there is integration
between the CLI and the web app.
So if you are a program
manager, a campaign manager,
you're responsible for doing
a bunch of code transformation
at scale and you want a place
to get pretty charts and graphs
to show your boss and stuff,
all of the status of the
campaign that you're running
in the CLI is automatically populated
in the AWS Transform web app
where you have pretty charts,
pretty graphs, you can see what
repos have been transformed,
which ones have been validated.
And of course, you've got
the agentic chat there,
so you can ask questions about the data.
You can say, what proportion
of them fit these criteria,
how many got done in the last
week, which ones had failures,
whatever you wanna ask it.
All right, now the fun part.
- [Venu] Cool, yeah, thank you.
Thank you so much, Morgan.
I have a question for
you before I get started.
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- [Venu] Customer asked,
"Can I do Fortran to Python?"
What's your answer for that?
- [Morgan] How big is your Fortran?
That's the question, right?
If you have, like,
you can do hello, world, any
language to any language,
and beyond that, the
complexity, it varies.
I don't want to, like,
over-promise to anybody.
We have a customer using some
weird esoteric old language
called Progress that I
had never heard of before,
that we didn't know if the model
was even going to understand,
and it totally groks it.
And they're putting, like, 100,000 lines
of code repos in there
effectively and making changes.
So again, I said best
practice, pilot, before.
Just try it.
It's cheap and easy to start and try.
We made the installation
as easy as possible.
It's one curl command to pull down our CLI
and start trying it out.
- [Venu] Cool, thanks.
Thanks for that.
Okay, let's now do some
coding, live coding, right?
So the way that I've set up is,
so Morgan talked about the
built-in transformations,
as well as the custom transformation
and doing it at scale.
So let's see if we can
do all of them, right?
So let's start with the out
of the box transformations,
and let's see how it works, right?
So the first thing is,
I mean, this is a command
line interface, CLI.
You can install it on your laptop.
So I'm gonna use a WSL
environment on Windows.
Mac and Linux is supported.
So I've already installed it,
and I'm just gonna start
with my first command.
So like Morgan mentioned, this can be run
as a interactive mode, as
well as non-interactive mode.
Non-interactive is basically
a bunch of commands.
You say, hey, ATX, run my
transformation on this repo.
They'll just go do it for you.
Or you can interact with
this, give some feedback
and do it interactively as well.
So we'll show both of
these modes right now.
So first thing, I'm gonna list...
Let's say, hey, atx custom,
that's AWS Transform custom,
definitions list, okay?
List all my definitions, right?
Okay.
Okay, so I have a bunch which I built,
but let's go through the
AWS managed ones, right?
So we have eight AWS
managed transformation,
which are out of the box, zero setup.
You can just get started.
There is AWS SDK v1 to v2, Node.js,
Python upgrades Boto2 to Boto3,
Python version upgrades,
Lambdas and non-Lambdas as well,
same thing with Node.js.
In early access,
we have the comprehensive
code base analysis,
which Morgan talked about,
and Java version upgrade,
again, it's both Maven,
Gradle build systems,
and x86 to Graviton.
And these are some of the user
transformation that I built
for demoing to customers and
for my personal use as well,
and this is the registry that you see.
So it's basically
published to the registry.
So once you publish it, any
user in your AWS account
who has access to this CLI
and proper IAM permission
should be able to view it.
Just download it and
run with their project.
- [Morgan] You're better than me.
When I demo it, I just use
the AWS internal registry,
and it shows, like, 350 transformations,
(Venu laughs)
which is good.
A lot of people internally are using it.
- [Venu] Yeah.
Awesome.
So let's start with the first one, right?
So I have a Lambda function here.
It's basically a to-do application.
So let's start by running
this transformation
on this Lambda function, right?
So...
And this is the command
that I'm gonna use, right?
Let's put this and then probably explain
what exactly I'm gonna do, right?
So this use case is basically,
hey, you're just going
to use out of the box.
You know what you're doing.
You have a bunch of Lambda
function, go run it, right?
Again, zero setup, just go run it
without creating your own
transformation, right?
So I'm gonna say, hey, atx custom exec.
Exec is execute.
And this is, -p is where is
my lambda function located.
- [Morgan] The file path on local disc.
- [Venu] Yeah, local disc.
And -n is the Python version upgrade
that you saw from the out of the box list.
C is, I mean, the bill
command that needs to be used.
So in case of this Python,
I'm just going to use no operations.
But for Java, you'd
use a mvn clean install
or something like that, right?
And the configuration is
basically additional context
that you could give, right?
That's the, basically,
what validation command
I need to use, right?
You can say, hey, I'm
gonna just run pytest
to make sure all unit tests pass.
And you can also give,
it's basically freeform.
You can give additional context here
of running this execution, right?
And I'm gonna say, hey...
Since this is very generic,
it can go from any Python
version to any Python version.
So I'm gonna say, hey, go to Python 3.3.
- x is basically non-interactive,
which means, hey, go run it.
And then -t is trust all tools.
So in case of interactive mode,
you might need to trust tools
to write files, read
files, all those things.
So I'm gonna say, hey, trust all my tools,
go and execute it, okay?
So let's execute this.
All right, so it started the
transformation right now.
Let's see what it does right now.
So basically, the first step,
it's going to create a conversation log
where you can track all the progress
and monitor all the progress
on the conversation log.
And you can resume these
conversations as well.
Accidentally, your
network got disconnected
and you control c-ed it,
there is a conversation id.
You can just resume this conversation.
That's a neat feature
because, I mean, sometimes
things happen, right?
Internet breaks down and
you have to reconnect,
you can do that here, right?
Okay, so let us do this job, right?
And I'm gonna show you an output,
what I did earlier in the day
for the same transformation,
how this is gonna look like, right?
So I have a dryrun folder here.
I just ran the same
transformation earlier in the day.
So basically, it ran
and it created the plan,
it created the, completed the changes,
and it basically converted
my Python function
from 3.8 to 3.13.
And let's see some of
these changes, right?
Because this transformation
might take anywhere
between 10 to 15 minutes,
I don't want you to just stare
at my screen, so we just-
- [Morgan] We are working
to make it a little quicker,
but we figured it's better
to be slow and right
than fast and wrong.
So we optimized for right.
Now, we're gonna optimize for fast.
- [Venu] Yeah.
Cool, yeah.
So this is the same project.
So it did a 3.8 to 3.13 migration.
And so it basically did a runtime upgrade,
and datetime was modernized
in this new versions,
and it also added 17 to
32 passing test cases.
And again, it documented what it did.
It also did improve
interpreter performance.
And this is all built in.
I didn't give any instruction.
It is all built in, right?
And it did not change any business logic,
no braking changes.
All those things are kept.
Okay, so it updated the readme.
These are the files changed.
I just did a git diff.
So what it does is once
it makes the changes,
it actually creates a local branch for you
and commits all these changes,
so which means at any point in time,
you can go to the comment ID, roll back,
or you can just compare and then review it
and then check it in or
push your code changes.
- [Morgan] It's especially useful
if the agent, like, does the right thing
for, like, the first three
quarters of the transformation
and then goes off the rails.
And you're like, I don't want
all that work to be wasted.
Like, you could just
revert to the previous-
- [Venu] Exactly.
Okay, so some of these
files had basically changed.
All the time zone things and
the main Lambda function,
it changed a few of the functions,
and also, requirements.text.
And it also changed the template.yaml.
I think this is a cloud
formation template I had.
So it changed from 3.8
to 3.13 for deployment.
And it also, it changed deprecated APIs,
documentation updates, all those things.
So again, just to summarize this,
just go run this out of
the box transformation
if you have a very similar use
case for your project, right?
So yeah, that's the first
thing that I wanna show, right?
Anything you wanna add in out of the box?
- [Morgan] No, I think that's good.
- [Venu] Cool.
Okay, let's now come to
the fun part where...
How do you wanna create your
custom transformation, right?
So here, I wanna show an internal library
that our internal team
used the same product
for migrating a internal ticketing system.
So we had something called Fluxo,
which Amazon's internal
ticketing system uses,
that's very old,
very hard to maintain,
so we wanted to change to
something called Tickety.
That's also an internal system,
but that's more API driven
and more performance oriented.
So that's why we wanted to
change all of our projects
which uses Fluxo to
Tickety library, right?
So that's, again, Java based,
but this is very specific to Amazon.
The large language models does not have
pre-trained data on these things.
So that's where the power comes in,
where you can feed in data or
context from your organization
to teach the agent how to do these stuff,
and then so it can do
that migration at scale.
- [Morgan] If you've got some
weird proprietary library
that no one else in the world uses,
that's what we're trying to show here.
- [Venu] Yeah.
So let's go do this one.
Okay, so,
let's go here.
Okay, the other thing I
want to also mention here
is this connects to MCP servers,
which means that you can pull in data
pretty much from anything, right?
So I have this Fluxo
ticketing migration guide,
which we have prepared,
and then I've just put
it into my GitHub repo.
It's a private repo.
So I'm asking
ATX custom to pull in doc information
from my internal repositories
and then use it as part of your creation
of the transformation definition, right?
So I'm gonna do this
in an interactive mode.
I'm just gonna say ATX.
That will open an interactive shell
where you can interact with it.
So I'm gonna create a definition
based on the migration guide that I have,
and then review it, give feedback,
then execute the transformation on that.
- [Morgan] And the cool thing
about this guide, by the way,
if this is that guide I sent you-
- [Venu] Yes.
- [Morgan] This is a guide
that was written for human users in Amazon
published to a wiki to
go and do this work.
Like, someone already wrote this guide
assuming developers were
gonna have to do it,
so we're just giving that to
the agent, no extra effort.
- [Venu] Yeah.
So I'm just gonna say, hey,
create a new transformation.
Okay, and this is the interactive mode.
Okay, so it's gonna ask you,
hey, what do you wanna do, right?
Language upgrades, framework migration,
library upgrades, all those things.
I'm just gonna say
internal library migration
from Fluxo to Tickety.
Again, the large language
model does not know
what the hell is Fluxo or Tickety, right?
That's where I'm gonna give
more information, right?
First, it searches in the registry
if somebody already created
this definition or not.
If not, it's gonna
create a new one, right?
Okay, so it's asking me,
hey, what kind of
application libraries it has?
What are the main functionalities?
What programming language it uses?
Hey, do you have any
migration guide documentation,
example code that you can give me,
that I can learn from it, right?
I'm gonna just say,
okay...
It referred to this dot md file
using my GitHub MCP server.
It takes a bit for connecting
and getting the right information,
basically started using the MCP tool.
Again, trusting this tool.
- [Morgan] You can also just
give it a local file path
to a file on disc.
- [Venu] Yeah, you can
download it and give...
But I just wanted to show the-
- [Morgan] Yeah.
- [Venu] Power of, hey, you can connect
to your existing environments.
Okay, so...
Okay.
Always fun with a live demo,
but yeah, it's doing it.
Okay, while this is running,
I think I was talking to
one of the customers here,
they had a use case for...
I have a prompt already written
using Kiro for increasing my
unit test coverage, right?
Can I do it on thousands
of my repositories?
Yeah, absolutely.
That's where the power comes in.
Hey, you already solved this problem,
automation problem once
with your existing AI tools.
Now you want to expand it or
scale it to all other teams,
you could definitely do that
with creating your own
custom transformation.
- [Morgan] Another scenario
I've heard of from customers
that I thought was pretty cool
is if you wanna make your code AI ready,
like you wanna write a
claude.md, a kiro.md file
for every repo under your ownership
and you wanna follow certain conventions
but incorporate aspects of the code there,
you can define how you want
those agent guide files to look
in Transform custom and have it go
just write all of those
files for all of your code.
- [Participant] So one thing is
when you have multiple problems
and you can see it sequentially
one after the another,
and one from the file
and the other from...
One prompt without an output,
and then another prompt
which rather than an
output, has an input...
So the sequential exhibition
of multiple count,
it's kind of a...
- [Morgan] So it's not exactly
a sequential execution of prompts.
There's several agents under the hood.
There's a planning agent,
and an orchestration agent,
an execution agent.
So the first thing it does when
you execute a transformation
is it's gonna look at the
transformation definition,
which itself has some steps and guidance.
It's gonna look at the code
you're asking it to operate on,
and it's gonna say, okay,
given these instructions
and this code, let me develop a plan
for doing this execution on
this particular piece of code.
And it will show that to you if you like,
and you can approve it or
tell it to make changes,
and then it's gonna go
through those steps.
And each of those is kind
of sort of like a prompt,
but there's sub...
It's not just a single one shot.
There's sub-steps in between
it because after each step,
the agent is going to
call a validation agent.
It's gonna make sure, hey,
does this code still build?
Does what I,
the action I performed in
this step actually fulfill
the original intent of this
step based on the plan?
- [Participant] Those things
are there in the prompt
I have the validation steps
as part of the prompt.
Everything's covered.
So do I need to remove it?
- [Morgan] I see.
- [Participant] And the
reason why validation...
Validates what it does...
- So what I would do is
I would take that prompt,
I would give it to AWS Transform
during the transformation
creation process and just tell it,
here's a prompt I wrote
for Kiro to do blah.
And it's gonna say, cool,
let me look at this prompt,
and there should be aspects of it
that are directly applicable,
and I'm just gonna incorporate that
into my transformation definition.
There's aspects I may ask
for your clarification on.
But it's gonna take that
kind of raw information
and put it in the
structured way that it knows
effectively executes
transformations with this thing.
- [Venu] That's where the
refined part also comes in
where you saw, right?
Once it generates, basically
converted your prompt
into its own, what we
call as the definition.
That's where you can
review it, you can edit it,
or you can just give feedback saying that,
hey, I really don't like
this validation step.
Can you add more, right, to this phase?
It should be able to accommodate that.
- [Participant] And then it would be...
If I have three prompts...
- [Venu] I mean, that's something
you need to experiment, right?
First, I would start with
one, how it creates it.
If that's not what you wanted,
maybe split it into multiple parts.
If everything can be contained,
yes, multiple prompts.
But again, as Morgan told,
it's basically a CLI.
So you create three transformation,
execute this in a batch,
should be able to do that as well.
- [Morgan] When in doubt,
I like to tell people
to break down problems
as small as possible,
as atomically as possible
'cause you'll get better results there.
But for really simple things,
you can mash them together,
and it'll probably work and
might save you a little effort.
- [Venu] Yeah.
Okay, cool.
It actually created a
transformation definition,
so let's look at the
transformation definition.
Okay.
Wow, it really is very comprehensive.
Okay, so this is the
transformation definition
that it created, right, for
the Fluxo to Tickety migration.
So let me, oops.
Okay, so it has a clear objective.
Hey, migrate code from my
deprecated Fluxo ticketing library
to modern Tickety SDK.
And what is the summary,
what exactly it's gonna do?
What is the entry criteria?
Entry criteria is basically,
hey, how do you wanna
take this code in, right?
So here, it says code imports
uses the Fluxo Java client.
That's the entry criteria, right?
- [Morgan] Entry criteria
is really cool, by the way,
because that's how the agent knows
does this transformation
apply to this code.
So if you point the agent at
a whole bunch of random code
that does not use Fluxo, it's
gonna read it a little bit
and be like, this doesn't apply, skipping.
So in the near future, we'll
have an assessment capability
where you can point the agent
at a whole bunch of code
and it'll tell you before
even transforming anything,
these transformations apply to this code,
and you can kinda stage it
out how you wanna do it.
- And implementation step
is basically step by step instruction.
It basically got information
from the migration guide
how to do this transformation.
First, hey, step one, update
the build dependencies,
and it basically broke it
down into these projects.
and client initialization,
hey, basically, how to
initialize the new client,
and basically covered
for Python type script,
all those things as well,
and get ticket operation.
All the APIs are also covered, right?
So these are the
implementation steps, right?
This is where as a domain
expert, you can come in and say,
hey, it looks good, it doesn't look good,
do we wanna change it or, or not, okay?
Okay, the last thing is the
validation criteria, right?
Yep, so the validation or exit criteria.
What is the goal that it want to,
the agent wants to achieve?
How am I going to satisfy?
So this is where, again,
we need to be very cautious
on how do we define this
validation criteria.
It could be just simple as,
hey, my build and unit test pass, right?
Or it could be very complex as...
So one of the customer's actually doing
an Angular to React migration.
They actually use a Playwright MCP server
to compare visually, hey,
my Angular and React,
does it look the same?
So it could be complex as that, right?
Or it could be deploying
it to an AWS environment,
checking if it works or not.
So that's where your expertise comes in.
How do you wanna validate
if this migration is successful or not?
All right, so this created a
good transformation definition.
And as a human in the
loop, you can view it.
You can modify it based on
the feedback, or apply it,
or publish to the registry, okay?
So let's apply it first
for a sample project.
Okay, so now it's asking me,
hey, where is your code repository?
And I'm gonna give this.
This is, again, one of the
sample projects that I have
which is in Fluxo that I
wanna migrate to Tickety.
Okay, so I'm gonna say,
okay, go ahead with this.
Now, again, it's gonna do the same thing.
It's gonna go analyze the entry criteria,
all the project files, and start
the transformation project.
So as Morgan described,
first, it does a planning,
so where it plans, hey,
how am I going to apply
this definition on this
current project, right?
What are the file changes
that needs to be done?
Again, here, you have an
option to modify the plan,
give some input.
Hey, this step does not
apply to this project,
so skip it, right?
You can do those things.
And then once the plan is approved,
it goes onto the execution mode, okay?
So let's see the plan creation.
Anything you wanna add to
the planning or the steps
while it plans?
- [Morgan] The important
thing to know is that
it's totally optional to review the plan.
You can tell the agent, just go for it.
It just depends on how
hands on you wanna be.
That's why, I mean, as
we've mentioned before,
this thing can run and very human driven,
like you're watching every
operation that it does,
approving every tool use that it does,
watching every file
manipulation that it does.
And you can always
control C it and pause it
and tell it, don't do that, do this.
So if you've got something
really complex or a piece of code
that you're very sensitive
about or whatever,
you can watch it every step of the way
and very carefully guide it.
Or you can YOLO mode it and just tell it,
do your best at everything.
It depends on how confident you are
in the quality of your transformation,
how risky this transformation
is to you and all that.
So you can be anywhere on that spectrum.
- [Venu] Yeah.
Another thing is, and
while, during the execution,
it also, the validation, right?
It validates it.
And if there are any errors,
it self-debugs the errors
and fixes as well, right?
We do have a self-debug
and validation agent,
which does that automatically for you.
- [Morgan] And if it can't
fix them, we try very hard.
So LLMs like to do this
fun stuff where they really
so badly want to say
that they did the job.
I mean, we've tried to
beat that out of the agent
as much as we possibly can.
Early iterations of
this would delete tests
to say all the tests passed,
like, all sorts of crazy stuff.
It's awful.
(Venu chuckles)
So we've built as many
guardrails as we could think of
to prevent this sort of behavior
and try to enforce some honesty here.
So if the agent is like, I
did five out of seven steps,
and I had trouble with these two,
and here's the trouble that I had,
like, we really try to make it honest,
because if you just go pop
this into Claude or something,
there's a good chance, like,
everything will look rosy
until you dig into it.
That's something that we've
encountered previously.
- [Participant] You guys
seem to be very focused
on code itself, like language code.
We have a challenge with cloud formation
and modernizing the CDK.
- [Morgan] Mm-hmm.
- [Participant] Is that the kind of thing
that this tool could do?
- [Morgan] There's people
doing Terraform to CDK
right now with this.
The way I think of it is if
you've got any structured text
and you want to turn
it into structured text
that looks different, yeah,
we could do that, yeah.
- [Participant] And then
you spoke a little bit
about deployables, right?
So like, actually deploying into accounts
and validating the deployments worked,
being able to blue to
green, or compare A to B
between what was there and
what could be there, right?
It's all capable?
I know to some degree, right?
- [Morgan] It's possible
if you build the scaffolding
around it, right?
Like, we're giving you,
put in text files and have
different text files come out,
and you can build the
scaffolding around it
to deploy it and return to the agent
information about validation
results and stuff.
- [Participant] With the CLI tool
being the sort of
mechanism for interaction.
So you're scripting around that tool-
- [Venu] Correct.
- [Participant] To get it to do
the other things that you want it to do,
but then turning to that client
to do the transformations
that are necessary.
- [Morgan] Exactly.
And honestly, like, I've seen
two extensibility approaches taken,
and it kind of depends on
what's working better for you.
So you can wrap our CLI
tool in your own stuff,
or you can tell our tool to
call external shell scripts,
external MCP tools, and
both approaches work.
It just kind of is, it's what's
better for your scenario.
- [Participant] Are the transformations
importable, exportable?
Can you run them to multiple...
(Morgan laughs)
- [Morgan] One of my core tenets
when we wrote the product
requirements for this
was that they would be
importable and exportable
because as far as I'm
concerned, this is your IP.
I don't want anything to do with it.
Keep it secret, open source, it, whatever.
That's the customer's.
They are fully exportable right now,
and they are 90% re-importable.
And the reason I have that
asterisk is because the RAG
or the knowledge items that it discovers
during an execution,
rehydrating the RAG database
where we store those
is not something that
we have gotten around
to being able to do on the import side.
So you can absolutely export it,
and you can mostly reimport it,
and we're getting that too to 100%.
- [Participant] Can you distribute this
around an organization?
Like, I know you guys were
talking about within an account.
But I mean, we're running this,
we're running an organization,
so could we have a central
account where this stuff lives
and then be able to distribute that out
across the organization?
- [Morgan] Cross account sharing
is something that is on our list.
It is not there yet.
But in the interim, you can export it.
Literally, when you export it,
it comes out as a zip file
with a bunch of stuff.
And then reimport it, and
you're not going to lose much.
And I can talk through what you'll lose
and how to get around it.
Yeah.
- [Participant] Can I review
the code that it generates
for the simple, like, transformation...
So can I explore the code that it used?
- [Morgan] So you can view
the plan that it generates
for upgrading your code,
for doing that particular
upgrade on your code.
The actual transformation
definition that we provide you,
we had lots of fights
with legal about this,
we do not share with
customers at this time.
That may change if I get my way,
but we don't share that right now.
- [Venu] But you can extend this.
You can extend it with
additional planned context
and other things, but
you can't really view it
and modify it right now.
- [Morgan] It's a black box
that you can tack things
on the outside of.
And I would like to have
it not be a black box
that you can modify, but we'll get there.
- [Venu] Okay, so this
is the plan it generated.
Plan, again, as I told, it's
basically how do I apply
my definition to this project, right?
Hey, first update the build dependencies,
then do the client initialization
and what files are gonna be changed,
what is the validation criteria
here, all those things.
Again, here, as a human in the loop,
you can basically review
the plan and provide input.
Here, I'm going to just
say, hey, looks good.
Proceed.
So this will be able to do that.
Again, in the interest of time,
I'm gonna go to my completed one.
I'm gonna show how exactly it did it
and how it created a summary, right?
So this is one of the things
that I did in the morning.
And so this is the migration
summary it created.
So what has been migrated
to Fluxo from Tickety?
So the dependencies,
this Fluxo Java client has been removed.
it added the Tickety
client authentication,
client initialization, what
it did, what are the changes.
Again, get ticket operation
before and after code snippet.
Basically, it completed all the changes
that is required for documentation updates
and other things for migrating,
so my proprietary internal
library to another version
or to a different system.
Cool.
So just quickly going through,
I have two more things
that I wanna quickly show.
One is the docs that I talked about.
Again, you saw in my list,
there is a comprehensive
documentation analysis.
Like, I'm just gonna do again.
So that's basically going
through your code documentation,
documenting all the code,
as well as creating the tech
debt analysis for your code.
So this is an early
access, so it basically,
it does a deep static
analysis of code base
and then generating it, right?
So I actually did this
for one of the projects.
I don't know how many of
you are familiar with Doom.
Doom is a gaming engine
that we all loved to play.
And that basically was...
I think it's 1990 it was created.
And this is pretty much
the documentation it had.
This is the original documentation.
Hey, go use Doom.
That's about it, nothing else, right?
So I ran my documentation
code base analysis on that,
and it actually created this
documentation folder, right?
Basically, it created a complete read me,
what exactly this code does,
what are the quick stats,
what is the documentation structure.
Basically, it created subcomponents.
- [Morgan] One thing I
really like is it creates
kind of this navigable structure
where the markdown files,
you can click between them
and it'll, like, navigate through them.
It's, like, kind of a
pseudo webpage, if you will.
- [Venu] Yep.
So, okay, so project overview,
it created a project overview,
and the file inventory,
how many total lines of
code, what all things.
And from architecture, it
basically created a component,
what are the components are available,
and basically created a
dependency mapping tree as well,
hey, main program, game
systems, core subsystems,
and then the utilities.
Okay, and what are the patterns this has?
Basically, analysis,
architecture, system overview.
And behavior is basically
the business logic,
like the use cases
and behavioral documentation
as well, right?
What are the weapon
properties, weapon mechanics,
which is used in the game?
Decision logic,
basically how the decisions
are being made in the code.
Error handling.
Workflows, what are the workflows?
So basically, it created
all the workflows for me.
- [Morgan] Make sure you
see the diagrams folder too.
I like the pictures.
- [Venu] Okay. I don't know...
Okay, maybe it didn't. (chuckles)
Oh, yeah, okay.
Maybe it created...
Yeah, there you go.
So this is the component diagram.
It has a main engine,
main program, game render,
sound, network, play simulation.
Okay, and abstraction,
foundation, external dependencies.
Cool.
And also, the main thing
is the technical debt.
Okay, so basically it's-
- [Morgan] Some code from 1990.
It found a few things.
- [Venu] Security order, the
security vulnerabilities,
outdated platform dependencies, of course.
- [Morgan] John Carmack probably
knows better than us but...
(Venu laughs)
- [Venu] So, okay.
1990 C coding practices. (laughs)
So, yeah.
Okay, cool.
So the last one I wanna quickly show,
I know we have 10 more minutes,
is the batch, right?
So how do you wrap this CLI into a batch
and run it across multiple
repositories, right?
Again, I used Kiro to create a batch,
and then basically an ATX batch launcher.
It basically takes a input of a CSV file,
which has my GitHub repositories,
and I'm gonna actually
run this documentation
on multiple GitHub repositories
and then go, hey, go run it, right?
And you can also provide
additional context.
What is the transformation name, right?
So basically, this is the CSV file,
and I just wrap my CLI
into a batch script,
and I thought, let's run this, right?
And I'm gonna run this script.
I'm gonna say, hey,
launch this batch script
with this CSV file in a
parallel mode, maximum 10 jobs.
You could increase it.
And this is the output directory to...
This is the clone directory
to download the clones from GitHub,
and then what is the output directory
where you need to do this.
So let's do this.
Oops.
Okay.
Okay, so I'm in a different
directory right now.
Give me one second.
Okay, so it's basically
checking the version
and running these commands,
starting, like, cutting
parallel jobs, right?
So let's...
Okay, so it basically downloaded
all the repositories for me
and then started running this.
And you can basically
monitor the execution locks.
It started creating it,
and you should be able to see the results.
Okay, yeah, so that's the batch mode.
Basically, wrap up the SEG execution
or the ATX execution
command, and then go run it.
- [Morgan] Our code name
was Super Elastic Gumby.
So sometimes, we slip
and say Gumby or SEG.
(Venu laughs)
I was really sad marketing
gave us a real name.
- [Venu] Yeah.
And the final thing is probably, let's...
And we talked about knowledge items,
so I wanna quickly show how
the knowledge items look, okay?
So I ran a bunch...
So I have created a transformation
called Java 21 modernization
for my bunch of Java projects that I had.
So I'm gonna say,
hey, I've run this multiple
times on multiple projects.
So I'm gonna say list-ki,
which is the knowledge items,
which is the continual learning aspect
where it learns from the agent execution.
Let's see how that looks.
So how we have designed
this is by default,
it will run with knowledge items,
which means it will
learn from the execution.
That's by default.
You can say do not learn as
well if you don't wanna learn.
And these knowledge items,
when they're created,
they're disabled by default,
which means a human in
the loop can review it.
And if they wanna apply
it for the next time,
they can enable it.
So here, if you see some of them, right?
Like, this is a Java 21
transformation, right?
Hey, it's found, hey, sealed
classes are incompatible
with JPA/Hibernate Lazy Loading, right?
And some of them are very specific.
Hey, SolarWinds, that's
one of the project I run.
It's very project specific.
It's not very generic.
And again, Spring Boot Virtual
Threads needs this, right?
So again, I can go and enable it.
So next time, it runs
the same transformation,
it finds that, and it basically
applies this knowledge item.
That memory is already there, so.
Okay, I'll give it to you for a wrap-up.
- [Morgan] Yeah, thank you for your time.
I think that's all we got.